whether it's with school closures
whether it's with masking whether it's
with vaccines the U.S
among sort of like Western Nations I
think has been uniquely aggressive in
their approach to most of these things
we are the only country that masked
two-year-olds there is no randomized
trial evidence
that shows that this is beneficial for a
two-year-old you know what what is the
what is the reduction in absolute
numbers of incidents of severe disease
for a two-year-old from wearing a mask
they have no clue and that's why the
World Health Organization says we don't
want little kids at that age wearing
masks the ecdc that's the European
version of the CDC they said we don't
want kids in Primary School wearing
masks at all but the United States if
you were to say I'm not so sure this is
a good idea for my six-year-old to be
wearing a mask again you were some
right-wing lunatic jerk